Now I can almost hear you at
home thinking okay dudes.
I got it.
Now what?
>> One of the first things you should
do is to think on your business model.
What is your profit model, and
how are you going to execute against it?
A few important questions that
could guide you in the right path.
Would you or someone you know that
represents the target audience
pay this amount for that service?
Why?
Are there any great alternatives
out there that are free?
What is your expected burn-rate?
How would you control it?
What is the gross margin?
What are the net margins?
How many sales do you need to
make in order to break even?
What is the worst case scenario for
your business?
How would you overcome it?
Lots of question, no?
Well, it's just a tool to
put us in the right path.
Even if some of these questions
are not applicable to you right now,
it's a good idea to address
them when you are ready.